this is a concept for a future family of  discoveries it's not a specific  replacement for the discoveries we have  today it has a lot of ideas in it both  finished design language and in the  technologies that are in it the  transparent hood creates the illusion  through cameras that you see nothing in  front of you but the terrain that's in  front of you now really talked to walk  Land Rover brand has always been about  and that's incredible all-terrain  capability we think the partnership is  great because we've all share the value  of adventure and exploration and also  the power of strong design like this car  here and that spaceship back there both  of these vehicles can take people to  places that they wouldn't normally go  but do that in style and safety and  comfort Land Rover has been the pioneers  of you like on land Virgin Galactic  pioneers of the air of space so it's a  beginning of a partnership which  something we're very excited about